Salut Romain, dis donc...
Oh pardon t'es tout nu !
- Non c'est rien, je prenais
un peu le soleil en t'attendant.
- Ah
Bah dis donc t'as... t'as froid non ?
- Ah non pourquoi ?
- Non non, pour rien...
*Introduction*
Il y a des choses dans la vie qui sont
tellement évidentes qu'on finit par les oublier.
Tenez, moi par exemple, quand j'ai testé la cabine de
cryothérapie
J'ai constaté une nouvelle fois deux
phénomènes naturels pourtant très familiers :
1 - La taille de mon pénis est
directement
corrélée à la température à
laquelle il est soumis.
Les deux diminuent en même temps.
C'est ce qu'on appelle le théorème
du captain igloo. [Ah, ah, ah]
2 - Quand j'ai froid, j'ai les tétons qui pointent
selon la loi, dite de Dark Vador
Alors vous allez me dire :
- "Merci captain Obvious"
- Et moi je vais vous répondre :
"Nain, nain, nain"
Vous êtes puéril quand même.
Non en réalité, ce que je vais vous répondre c'est :
Ok tout le monde sait ça
mais est ce que tout le monde sait pourquoi ?
Et là à ce moment-là, vous, vous allez me répondre ...
bon OK c'est chiant.
Bref vous savez pourquoi ?
Non ? Bon ! Eh bah on y va !
Alors, commençons par le pénis
et surtout mettons nous d'accord sur les chiffres
Le pénis devient petit quand il fait froid
mais c'est quoi un petit pénis au fond
enfin au fond...
Et bien un pénis de taille moyenne c'est
9cm au repos et 13cm en érection
Bon pour rester dans la bienveillance et l'absence de jugement
on va dire qu'on peut parler de taille de pénis inférieure à la moyenne basse
quand on passe sous la barre des 7cm au repos
et 10cm en érection
Et on parle de micropénis en dessous de 8cm en érection
Voilà, comme ça le décor est planté.
Pour être complet sur le sujet on peut ajouter que
la taille au repos n'a pas de lien direct avec la taille en érection
On pourrait aussi dire qu'on peut tout à fait avoir une
avoir une sexualité normale et très satisfaisante pour tout le monde
avec une pénis de petite taille,
mais on s'égarerait parce que ça n'est pas le sujet.
Non aujourd'hui la question qui nous intéresse c'est
pourquoi le pénis joue à l'escargot timide
sous l'effet du froid ?
Et bien c'est un mécanisme de défense,
non pas du pénis,  mais du corps tout entier.
Pour être précis c'est un mécanisme de défense
contre le froid, qui est vécu comme une menace
par notre organisme qui cherche à tout prix
à maintenir une température centrale optimale
pour que tout fonctionne correctement.
La température centrale c'est la température qui règne
à l'intérieur de notre corps.
En temps normal elle est comprise entre 36°
et 37,5 degrès
Quand notre corps se rend compte que la température extérieure diminue,
il protège ce qu'il a de plus précieux : ses organes vitaux.
Et désolé de vous l'apprendre, mais le pénis n'est pas un organe vital.
Et non.
Donc l'organisme veut garder ses organes internes
bien au chaud et pour ça, il a un truc.
Pour éviter la déperdition de chaleur par la circulation sanguine,
il diminue la taille des vaisseaux qui irriguent
les tissus extérieurs.
Il calfeutre les portes de sorties en fait.
C'est ce qu'on appelle la "Vasoconstriction périphérique"
Ok, vous voyez pas le rapport ?
On va procéder à une petite reconstitution
Romain, tu peux venir s'il te plaît ?
Alors...
voilà
Voici un pénis de taille normale
Exposons-le à un froid intense.
Il grelotte.
Mais, c'est pas fini.
La température extérieure a brutalement chuté
On met les VIP au chaud et on bloque les issues.
Euh, mais le pénis est resté enfermé à l'extérieur là !
Balek'
Ok..
"bip bip bip"
"tut tut tut"
Donc les vaisseaux qui irriguent la peau
et les extrémités rétrécissent,
et comme à la différence du nez, des oreilles
ou des doigts, le pénis n'a pas de structure solide, hein,
il est composé de corps spongieux et de corps caverneux
et bien tout ça se rétracte
Tout ça se RETRACTE !!
Pffffff
Wow, tu le fais hyper bien !
Et voilà, c'est bon ? Vous l'avez ?
Pour remédier à cette situation embarrassante,
il y a la technique dîte de "l'élastique"
bien connue des pratiquants des sports collectifs
et de leurs vestiaires complexants et impudiques.
Il s'agit de saisir le prépuce, ou la base du gland hein,
(si on ne possède plus de prépuce)
et de tirer dessus,
délicatement,
pour tout déplisser.
Je déconseille en revanche toutes les techniques
d'exposition à des sources de chaleur.
Pour des raisons évidentes de sécurité.
Pas seulement pour des raisons de sécurité d'ailleurs.
Parce que si contrairement aux organes féminins
le matériel reproducteur de l'homme est placé
à l'extérieur du corps
c'est parce qu'il supporte mal la chaleur.
D'ailleurs le slip chauffant,
c'est un moyen de contraception.
C'est vrai que ça coupe l'envie
Bon, et les tétons alors ?
Et ben on en est pas vraiment sûrs, mais on suppose
que ce qui est en cause c'est un vieux réflexe dont on a
dont on a déjà parlé dans la vidéo "5 preuves qu'on est des animaux".
Ils s'agit du réflexe pilo-moteur qui est responsable de
la chair de poule et qui fait se contracter
des petits muscles chargés de faire dresser les poils sur notre peau
Et bien il y a des petits muscles du même type,
des muscles lisses, c'est à dire qu'on ne les contrôle
pas volontairement, dans les aréoles qui entourent nos mamelons.
Oui, on dit mamelon, pas téton
c'est moche mais c'est comme ça.
Et quand ces petits muscles se contractent,
l'ensemble se resserre et se durcit.
C'es bon ou je fais revenir Romain?
Maintenant qu'on a levé le voile sur ces phénomènes intriguants
ce que j'ai envie de vous dire,
aimez-vous comme vous êtes,
quelque soit la taille de votre pénis ou la forme de vos mamelons
Ok c'est chelou.
Bon, on s'en fout
aimez-vous comme vous êtes,
à très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos et d'ici là,
mettez-vous bien et surtout, portez-vous bien,
voilàà